today is giving Tuesday it's a movement
that began back in 2012 to boost
charitable giving at the end of the year
people donated more than two hundred and
eighty 1 billion dollars to charities
last year a new Bank rate survey out
this morning says forty percent of
people give money but fraud is a big
problem here two government agencies are
warning consumers to be wary of scammers
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to tell you what to
look for good morning to you Jill this
just happened to me yesterday I got an
email from David Rubenstein who's a very
well-known philanthropist asking me to
donate to a charity and I was just about
to click on and do it but it's signed we
all have a lot to be thankful for it
Dave know he never saw I've never known
him to be a Dave I emailed him and said
is this you and he says no it's not but
if he hadn't signed if this person
hadn't signed it Dave I would have never
questioned it because I didn't
double-check the email until I became
suspicious well good for you a
well-played oh it sure is and you know
earlier this year the IRS actually
warned that charitable frauds are on the
rise and it usually coincides with a
disaster maybe hurricane relief but just
like you said it can happen from any
area so I know everyone's gonna get
inundated with asks today and throughout
the end of the year a little healthy
skepticism would be great and the most
important thing to remember please
please tell everyone you know don't be
giving cash don't send wires don't share
your personal information this is
identity theft as well one of the key
characteristics of these frauds is that
they will tend to sound like a charity
that you're familiar with so it may not
be the American Cancer Society they may
change it to the American Cancer
organization something that's close but
not the actual charity so what are the
safest ways to send your money well the
safest ways generally speaking would be
to be clear have a you know check a
credit card a text is fine you've got to
keep good records if you want to check
to see whether the charity is legitimate
the IRS has a great tool that you should
be looking at it will help you
understand whether or not it has a tax
ID number so just all you to do is IRS
gov plus charity you'll get to the tool
that's a wonderful way to check on that
how do you check it sorry Nora how do
you check if you the percent of the
money that you're giving is going to the
cause your donor
- I love this organization it's called
Charity Navigator it compares how each
of these organizations is spending money
and doesn't in the actual category so if
you want to give for education or you
want to get to the arts it will look at
each one
generally speaking we like to see that
75% of your money goes to the charities
out ultimate outcome rather than the
overhead if you're seeing half and half
that's not a good sign so check that out
Charity Navigator org really a helpful
site now this cameras are really good
yeah they are and you know what healthy
skepticism that's what I want to really
point out healthy skepticism all right
Jill thank you very much appreciate it